[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a science fiction comedy drama
television series called upload spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
in the year 2033 the world has become
entirely digitalized the most outrageous
invention is the virtual afterlife it is
a place where people can stay after
their death and enjoy all the
materialistic things that they couldn't
have when they were alive when a person
dies his body is frozen and his
consciousness is uploaded to the
afterlife of his choice he basically
becomes like a character in a video game
but with consciousness and memories this
way one can live for eternity talk to
their friends and family who are still
alive and even meet them once they die
and are brought to the digital heaven
this process of joining the virtual
afterlife is called upload it is managed
by a large corporation that employs
thousands of programmers to make the
afterlife as realistic as possible one
of such employees is 25 year old nora
her job is to guide new uploads through
heaven and help them settle in she talks
to them via a program and can meet them
as her virtual self nora dreads her job
but continues working because it will
give her an employee discount if she
ever wishes to be uploaded after her
death then we are introduced to a 27
year old computer engineer nathan he is
driving his automatic car to a family
dinner the car is installed with all the
safety precautions and is driving itself
but nathan wishes to race down the
street he uses an illegal hard drive and
changes the settings to manual the speed
causes a police drone to chase after him
but nathan makes up an excuse and gets
out of the situation at home he is with
his family and his wealthy girlfriend
ingrid nathan is not in love with her
because of her overly clingy and
protective personality she doesn't
belong to his world which is more family
oriented unlike hers who only care about
money and fame upon seeing nathan dance
with her niece ingrid gets jealous and
asks him to come with her in the
following scene they are in the back of
his car making love nathan stops at the
grocery store and drives back home later
on the way a strange automatic car
malfunction takes place as a result he
crashes into a truck and is heavily
injured he is rushed to the hospital and
told that he can either be uploaded or
die traditionally ingrid arrives with a
contract for his upload even though
nathan doesn't want to spend the
entirety with her in a moment of panic
he signs the contract under ingrid's
family upload plan and is officially
registered following this he is kept on
an inclined chair and decapitated the
next thing nathan hears is nora's voice
she has been assigned as his guide nora
asks him a series of questions to ensure
his senses are fine she also creates his
avatar and gives him a slight hair lift
then nathan finally comes to his senses
and finds himself in a lavish room that
will be his for the rest of eternity
nora tells him he is in the lakeview
afterlife one of the most popular
packages that their company offers
everything in this afterlife is designed
to match his preferences for instance
the building near the hotel is a bowling
alley for him but it is a church for
someone else he can meet new people and
make friends until his family members
die in the real world the change is too
sudden for nathan when he starts crying
nora calms him down telling him that
everything will be better tomorrow she
makes him go to sleep and continues
working with someone else the next
morning nathan wakes up and finds out
that in-app purchases require money he
cannot pay through his own account
because he is here on ingrid's family
upload plan this is when he realizes
that she has the power to do anything
she wants with him and can even delete
him through his balcony nathan can see
the full view of the lake he can even
change the seasons as per his wish after
taking in the view he meets ingrid's
grandmother who is black and white
because the reference for her avatar was
taken from an old picture he also calls
ingrid and sees that she is at a party
enjoying herself this only makes nathan
miss his former self before ending the
call she says that he cannot run away
from her now the comment makes nathan
feel strange but he dismisses the
feeling meanwhile nora is at home with
her father he has a health condition
that is bound to kill him soon nora
wants him to save money for the upload
program but he refuses because he wants
to be with his late wife who he thinks
is an actual heaven back in the
afterlife nathan goes to the lobby for
breakfast and is stunned by the meal
options they have however right at 10
o'clock the food disappears leaving him
disappointed he then meets a fellow dead
man named luke the food is just a
program designed to look and taste like
the real stuff nathan is shocked that
the company charges them for it because
it costs them nothing to make wait until
nathan hears about nfts luke introduces
him to a flow of current called the
torrent it is a pathway between the real
and virtual worlds which is extremely
dangerous most people who cannot get
used to the virtual world commit the
unthinkable by jumping into it as a
whole nathan likes some things about the
place like the water pressure in the
shower and the fact that he can pee
anywhere but he would still rather be
alive than in the supposed heaven a man
informs him that there are thousands of
people in the resort right now but as
per the program they can only see a
common number this causes some glitches
which mess with nathan's head everywhere
he goes he is addressed as mr brown and
every staff member knows him his hair is
also too spiky for his liking which
makes him lose his mind soon nathan
becomes frantic and thinks of ending it
all he is making his way to the torrent
when nora arrives and stops him she
explains that the new world might seem
unnatural at first but it is like any
other man-made thing when he gets used
to it she asks him to give it a day or
two and he agrees nora even tells him
her real name because he had been
addressing her as an angel until now a
while later nora gets off work when she
is not around her computer deletes files
from nathan's memories on its own at
home she meets her date on an app called
the nightly they place cameras on each
other's chests and say that they consent
before making love it turns out that
placing the camera before sex is a
compulsory protocol in today's world
they can even rate each other on the app
afterwards the following day nathan is
assigned to pet therapy because of what
he tried to do yesterday he is paired
with a golden retriever but one that
actually talks a therapist from the real
world is controlling the dog because it
is only a medium to make the patient
feel better as a productive homework
assignment nathan is asked to write the
names of five people he meets today in
the meantime nora comes to her boss with
paperwork that says her father is
entitled to her employee discount but
she is denied the discount because only
the employees with 4.6 ratings or above
can get it but nora has
4.59 the difference is insignificant but
her boss doesn't care in the afterlife
nathan calls ingrid and finds her in a
spa getting stem cell injections and
vaginoplasty she is getting ready for
his funeral tonight but is more excited
about the decorations than getting to
see him following the call he goes
looking for new people to write about
them in his diary he meets a kid named
dylan who died at the age of 12 and has
been there ever since but the kid is too
busy fighting the game mode thugs to
talk to him next he meets david choke
the former owner of the second largest
privately owned company he is worth
billions of dollars and is enjoying a
lavish afterlife on being asked what he
did for work nathan reveals that he and
his friend jamie were making an app that
allowed people to make their own
afterlife where they can live with their
families that way they wouldn't have to
pay a hefty sum to the current owners of
lakeview for a bunch of unnecessary
programs after listening to this david
casually says that nathan was murdered
since he was about to make a six billion
dollar company go bankrupt he was
probably murdered by the owners nathan
refuses to believe him and walks away
back on the earth nathan's cousin
detective fran is asked by nathan's
family to investigate his death she
finds nathan's car in a junkyard which
is still functioning the car refuses to
acknowledge that it is damaged which
means that it has been tampered with
fran makes a note of this and continues
the investigation in the next scene
nathan is with nora telling her that he
cannot remember some parts of his life
like the name of the app he was
developing this reminds nora of the time
she found a chunk of his memory files
missing she promises to look into it but
gets busy with other clients nora
desperately needs a five-star rating to
get her success rate up but dylan gives
her only three similarly she gets no
luck in impressing the clients that day
nathan notices this and gives her
several five stars she tells him
everything that is bothering her and
feels a lot lighter afterward without
them knowing the two are developing
feelings for each other upon reaching
home nora looks for the missing data
from nathan's memory she cannot find
them but is unable to get her hands on
the memories that come right after the
deleted parts nathan and his friend
jamie have just come out of a business
meeting a man asks them if they have
told someone from the big companies
about the idea nathan says only his
family and girlfriend know the entire
interaction seems strange to nora so she
decides to save the clip for later the
following week a very important
invention is about to be tested the
scientists are trying to download people
from the afterlife to their normal
selves in the world the first download
is about to be broadcasted
internationally at the same time nathan
is getting ready for his funeral under
ingrid's supervision she makes him wear
clothes he is not comfortable wearing
and takes the entire control of his life
nathan is excited about the download
feature because if it is successful he
might get back to his old form they
watch the first test take place and are
shocked to see the test subject's head
explode the experiment is unsuccessful
but nathan still has hope that he will
return home one day later that day the
funeral party starts in la new york and
in the virtual world nathan comes to the
party with luke in new york nora also
visits his funeral nathan had thought
that it would be filled with his friends
and people he likes but instead none of
them have come because of a game he is
the most shocked about jaime being
absent his mother also reveals that the
money they got from his share of the
company was not a lot the party doesn't
even seem to be for nathan as everyone
socializes among themselves when he
calls out ingrid for the lame planning
they get into an argument she pulls out
the big guns threatening to delete him
all together in the end nathan has to
reluctantly apologize nora watches all
of this take place and feels bad for him
detective fran is also at the funeral
she finally gets to talk to nathan and
asks him if he has any enemies she also
discloses that his vitals were improving
before he was taken to be uploaded on
the day he died nathan knows fran for
being strange so he doesn't think much
about the comment later that night nora
returns home and calls the guy she saw
in nathan's memory earlier he introduces
himself as josh but refuses to tell her
anything about the meeting he had with
nathan in the last scene nathan is in
his bed calling jaime again but like
always he doesn't pick up it is strange
because they used to be best friends
before his death subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching